miranda did you know that you're a bit
of a viral moment on tick tock i do i
was just telling him about it i actually
do cuss a little do you also what's your
favorite curse word probably
a clip from an interview you did i think
back in 2020 with whitney cummings and
people have been going bananas on it uh
basically like all sorts of celebrities
joe jonas josh peck yeah my friend josh
oh my gosh i actually do cuss a little
do you also what's your favorite curse
word probably
did it so joe jonas did it sophie turner
lizzo what do you make of all the hype
right now i actually do cuss a little do
you also what's your favorite curse word
probably
yeah well my friend whitney and i were
doing that interview and um after i we
had the exchange we had and then she
like laughed really hard it's kind of
funny because like everyone on tick tock
thinks it's me laughing but it's my
friend whitney laughing and i keep
texting her like you framed me
you know all of tick-tock it's like
making fun of me
no but also how you said probably bleep
is so innocent and then it's like
like evil
but yeah it's really funny i love seeing
all the videos it's hilarious i'm wrong
are you gonna give it a shot the tick
tock world yeah well she was talking she
was telling me about it you should y'all
should do it together i wanted him to do
my part though yes and she said yeah she
told me i was like what's your part and
she like you know
just said it to me like so calmly and i
was like whoa you're left scrolling yeah
i was like whoa i scared him and then
she and then i was like so you said that
on your tic tac and she's like oh no i
don't even have tick-tock and i i'm just
a voice of tick tock i'm like that's big
time you don't even have tic tac and
you're going viral on tickets you've
made it you've made it miranda is that
still your favorite word
yes it's still my favorite
i mean when i watched nickelodeon as a
kid it was always about the sliming so
to hear that there's gonna be a thousand
that's pretty incredible um how are the
two of you bonding though to get that
chemistry and that dynamic between the
two of you just right for showtime well
when we were doing the promos they
basically threw us right into it and i
got to um make him do a bunch of like
push-ups burpees push me around on what
was that thing i don't even know what it
was it was a sled yes
okay who is on your mus slime bucket
list if there's any celebrity you could
slime who would you love to slime up
there on that stage
i think it'd be fun to slime adele and i
think katy perry probably had like the
best like craziest sliming at the kid's
choice words of anybody ever yeah so
maybe katy perry
[Music]
you